this week conflict zone is in Berlin
where the president of Afghanistan
Ashraf Ghani has been holding talks with
German officials some 80,000 of his
people have sought asylum here in
Germany this year alone but with
improved human rights being promised at
home and a crackdown on corruption why
are so many Afghans still wanting to
leave
president Ashraf Ghani welcome to
conflict zone in the first eight months
of this year we've seen the highest
number of civilian casualties in
Afghanistan we've seen a hundred
thousand people more displaced around
the country how much worse is it going
to get well thank you for inviting me
we've had one of the most difficult
years if not the most difficult year of
the last 15 years we're standing we've
ensured the survival of the state
because that was what was it stick
how much worse will it get it depends
how much regional cooperation we can
secure and how much international
mediation and pressure can be exerted to
create rules of the game between states
in a regular concern mr. president seems
to be the human rights violations by
local or national militia groups that
are loyal to you to the government we
don't have militias whether UN reported
in August and in the first world this
year prior prior to my assumption of
office some of the local police were
behaving like militias we have issued
orders that all people with political
affiliations will not have local police
serving them at all these orders being
obeyed they are being a bit their
windows in August in the first half of
this year according to the United
Nations these groups carried out with
impunity deliberate killings assaults
extortion in today was heart and
property they were part absolutely and
that was supposed to be the good side
the good sites were formed at the height
of the war by your forces as well so
what you saying it's our fault
no it's the information so I know on the
contrary it was a set of conditions that
produce these these were short-sighted
measures to deal with mediums
term issues and what we have learned and
what we are focused on is not a to
engage in blame games second to define
the problem and solve it
not to perpetuate okay but the UN's
definition of the problem and it says
that the interlocutors in your country
reported that government authorities
were consistently unwilling or unable to
control the act that it is not
programming group that is not accurate
as I brought to your attention you're
describing August I'm describing
November we have taken systematic
measures and we've secured the consensus
move the powerful political protection
that these groups had a significant part
of them look at unders I was in Kunduz
on on Thursday and announced an end to
groups that would be tolerated we have
had a difficult legacy of 40 years and
cleaning up is not going to be a one
day's job but we are engaged in a
systematic effort we have not allowed
formation of new militia groups and we
are reforming the local police
systematically so that they would not be
abused and what about the political
connections of these commanders whom
this is your government officials
admitted to you nama earlier this year
they were unable to disarm them disband
or hold them accountable what I'm saying
the legacy legacy cannot be cleaned up
in one day but we are engaged in
systematic efforts to reform the local
police reform the National Police the
army is much better especially our
Special Forces and thank God there are
no allegations even in the worst of
Fighting's of human right abuses by the
army the rest is a package and it will
be dealt with systematically how do you
deal with the climate of impunity that's
grown up for so long the climate of
impunity first is rule of law on
Thursday our reformist new chief justice
change the justices of all 34 provinces
and it started as systematic set of
enquire
second is to deal with corruption the
Kabul Bank case that became the emblem
of impunity has been dealt with we've
already collected 450 million dollars
out of the 800 million dollars that were
stolen from the public purse how do you
say it's been dealt with mr. president
when just a month ago a prominent
businessman hallelula froz who's
supposed to be serving a 15 years and
he's back in prison
he's risen but he was out of prison a he
was smiling with government officials
this is precisely again I'm bringing to
your attention that corruption was
systematic feature we got that out of
jail he was older he was serving his
sentence at night but he was during that
necessary cycle it's a minute
the minute this became public I ordered
that he be placed in prison in solitary
confinement 20 million dollars have been
paid by him out of his debts the
property that allegedly he was using to
partner on is now under legal process of
being confiscated but what conclusion
are people supposed to draw when this
man gets a 15-year sentence and the next
days I've glad-handing with your
officials at an ethical shift that
officials have been dismissed I mean my
legal my legal adviser was responsible
for this the legal adviser has been
suspended a full inquiry is underway to
deal with this if it makes a mockery
doesn't it of justice it makes a maker
and makes is meritorious is jacory when
impunity is not dealt with it on the
contrary sends a signal of resolve when
cases like this that were the norm are
being dealt with in his back and in
prison in Assen sulci confinement and
under close attention that medical
director is he just elusive in Niger
cases in Bagram in background there no
day/night distinctions
earlier prior to my assumption of office
he not only refused to pay a cent he in
effect had a wink of a present reserved
for him so you were surprised when
he turned up with this government
officials were you I was that's
precisely my shock was having trumpeted
the idea that that is a symbol of your
life years old my shock turned not into
anger but into action
not into impotent rage but into action
and it sent a very strong signal that I
will not tolerate I want to ask you
about signals you said you've been asked
about this before General Abdul Rashid
Dostum a man who you once labeled as a
known killer you ran with him as your
running mate for the election and you
said general Dostum is accepted as a
charismatic leader by a significant
number of my countrymen and women it's
out of respect for their belief in him
that we've joined forces that's correct
does that make the crimes that he
committed okay whatever they were if
there are crimes he's asked for an
inquiry is your only person killer is an
only person that is apologized as part
of running and it's a very difficult
environment needs to be you're going to
ask me in two minutes about peace I was
neither I don't know about Northern
Ireland what is what has happened peace
requires conflict countries that have
engaged in long term conflict require
healing but at least for people to admit
what they've done was the professor of
mystery doesn't admit misgiving he has
not been tried in a court he has not
been found guilty his apology was the
most general of ecology is it Finland
was it little enjoy anyone else that's
not the point is that it's the point
because a lot of people in your country
regarded this as wholly inadequate
didn't they wholly inadequate none of
your successes judge do you judge do you
speak for my people or do my people have
voice to speak for themselves well I'm
quoting from your people actually with
Cypriot all ammaji dedi the former
president afghan of afghanistan well yes
it is a very close friend of you said
this was inadequate he said Allah will
never accept the apology of a person who
has committed crimes and killed a person
because Allah
never forgives those who kill innocent
men so he's not at all happy Jenna and
John contracted Human Rights Commission
was it at all happy with this either our
point so I thought my judgment yes is we
are a free society we engage in debate
and that's our characteristic and
because of this our job is to heal and
to move forward not to perpetuate not to
get bogged down we have moved to
measures in criteria that all of us
agree or important that human right
based approaches are a must and what is
important is to be able to move towards
these goals in a sustainable manner not
through emotional outbursts and not
understanding the context of what we're
facing and taking the people with you at
the same time because all the opinion
polls at the moment show you're losing
trust among the Afghan people last year
according to the Asia Foundation 54%
thought the country was going the right
way now this year it's 36% it's great
you've lost almost 20% that is correct
but look at the context we've dealt with
three transitions an economic transition
caused by the departure of over 600,000
troops and contractors that are the most
important consumers in spenders in the
country in this context we are still we
have had to impose an austerity program
because the promises of that one
government to the international
community are not credible and we have
carried credible programs just a few
days ago you urge the crowd of people
not to leave the country you said our
dignity our respect is in Afghanistan it
is if you can't guarantee them security
or an economy that works dota feels they
do guarantee security in Paris look mr.
Sebastian we are dealing with new
threats threats that are global and our
fight is been for survival in the midst
of bombing in in London did you ask for
Prosperity or did you ask for survival
our case is one of national survival and
it must be grasped as to what the world
this year was about it was to create two
political geographies in Afghanistan to
end the constitutional system in what we
believe in in the reform path that we've
embarked we've come out of this a year
ago no one was giving bath when security
forces the chance to be able to stand at
this time of the year
tall and being able to defend but your
call to people who didn't go down well
with everybody one person in the crowd
said how will they understand our pain
their own children study live and are
having fun in Europe and America he has
a point doesn't he I mean the families
the families of leaders in Afghanistan
they live abroad the families of your
vice presidents live in Turkey and Iran
family of your chief executive is in
India families of the top cabinet
ministers presidential advisers deputy
ministers all outside the country
well that's we have a complex diaspora
and but how you want those the ordinary
people to stand when all those
privileged elite the president in
general it elites a part of the
globalization moment that we live in
what is significant is to create
opportunities for the generations to
come in the point remains if the
families of the privilege live abroad
they are not going to have careers of
the careers are back in Evanston no
remover
they must we create we have to create
the conditions if they live abroad they
become dishwashers they don't become
become part of the middle class
you didn't you did wrong I don't
identify that exchangers I did extremely
well I did extremely well but it was
part of my commitment I'd signed an
agreement that I would work one year for
every year of the scholarship that
allowed me to go and the minute the
opportunity was created in 2001 I'd
returned I hope that the new generation
of Afghans will have the same sense of
patriotism and respond to the conditions
of our country if people stay are they
going to get listened to
other complaints going to get
that's gosh the reason I asked is the UN
Development Programme discovered in
April that out of more than 2,000
complaints about the police which were
referred to the Inspector General in
your interior ministry in a year just
nine were family and it's this or
prostitution fired just same as under
general the same inspector general what
needs you to believe it's it's just one
man it's because we've dealt was the
Ministry of Interior is responsible for
the whole house inversely they were ten
billion over ten billion dollars of
investment were poured into the Ministry
of Interior but the systems were weak
what we are focusing on now and both in
the Ministry of Interior whether it's
from procurement of use of public money
to the systems is an overhaul but this
is again being done in the middle of an
imposed war ernest where the police the
same police that are accused of
corruption and some of them are in not
listening have done heroic things such
as embrace a suicide bomber in order to
save the population both sides need to
be understood both faces one faces ugly
the other face is ruined we need to
remove the ugliness and ensure that the
heroic focus is enhanced so that the
police can become respectable no no time
to find a new attorney general so far
the Attorney General's we've failed and
we we will find one it is a failure and
I acknowledge senior law officer whose
mission is to use the law to protect and
serve the people that's not you and
that's that influential Attorney General
so deny acknowledged failure with we
failed to do this and we're determined
to make the appointment so but you did
still find the time to propose a pretty
draconian amendment to the Criminal
Procedure Code didn't you that would
allow for indefinite detention without
trial why when you were so critical of
American methods in Guantanamo do you
adopt the same kind of NFL if not
indefinitely detention without trial
we're dealing with suicide bombers on a
daily basis we are dealing with a weak
judicial system where people who were
given 20-year sentences in the primary
court
sentences will reduce because of
corruption in the courts to six months
or a year and then did not serve our
security forces thought this was a
mockery and people were getting out with
impunity and repeatedly committing
crimes because of this there was need
for a signal in a time of national
emergency to be able to do this but the
procedure again you need to understand
and I respectfully bring it to your
attention
it's the Supreme Court that makes the
decisions not the administer but human
rights groups think this is a mockery
because there is doesn't there's no
specifying whether the detainee will
have access to family members or to a
lawyer or the right to examine the
evidence against interest or the right
to travel that evidence the court system
can ensure whence the Supreme Court is
chart with this and we have in in
excellent chief justice whose integrity
and commitment to law is second to none
can ensure that and these detainees us
to be kept supposedly in a special place
under the supervision of the prosecutor
separate from detention centers and
prisons what kind of places are do these
are these black sites Allah CRE oleksiy
no black sites it's the pattern the per
one detention facility that is
specifically geared to provide maximum
access to rule base without oversight
oversight is that by the Supreme Court I
just brought to you and how do we know
that they are going to do that properly
as a void as the Supreme Court has
avoids the UT and willful abuses that
we've seen in other detainees that the
human rights community is silent with
the megaphones that they have there's
going to be silence were there any
abuses voice is not absent enough when
it's their voice is present and it's
paid attention to countries can get away
with this
when there is no voice when there is
voice accountability follows you have a
national action plan to end torture but
how much faith can people put into that
according to you nama the UN assistance
mission in Afghanistan only one member
of the Afghan security forces has ever
been prosecuted
for the torture or ill treatment of
detainees how can people then have faith
in this new plan that people are going
to be brought to kick us off because
abuses because of leadership one man
ever that's you're describing to me the
past you're not describing to me the
present and the intentions so the
president hasn't happened yet in the
form that you're describing but that's
precisely what we are focused to one
we're never in denial in acknowledged
what we are dealing with what kind of
legacy is there and how this legacy must
be confronted in solved judges by our
action a year from now to see whether
what we've put in place is going to be
effective or not because both
international organizations and national
human rights organizations are
extraordinary active in will document
well what are the things that they're
active about is the rights of women and
one of your biggest promises concerns
sure the rights of women you've
committed to this as a priority equality
empowerment of women I want to show you
a picture that emerged on September the
first which was published by Human
Rights Watch yes and it apparently shows
the lashing of a 22 year old woman named
Jean Nina who was arrested in Gore
province a few weeks before she and a
man were accused of zina which I gather
his sex outside marriage a crime
carrying a sentence of between five and
fifteen years in jail they were
sentenced instead to a hundred lashes
each by a formal court part of your
judicial structure that knows very well
that lashing is illegal why is this
still going on first foot then queries
been made this is horrifying isn't it
any horrifying before we put it away
I mean it is a horrifying picture do you
want me to hold it to the public and
they liked it you know I'll be delighted
no strangers to our shame with inherited
situations that are shameful that are
absolutely The Skeptical despicable and
in [ __ ] we want to make sure that war
is made secure for a rule-based approach
but again
transformation of gender relationship
that's one side of the equation the
other side is ministers ambassadors
members of parliament were extraordinary
articulate who or extraordinarily
committed and I had the honor to
nominate the first woman ever to the
Supreme Court she fell short of approval
by Parliament by only nine votes in next
year again and women at peace
negotiations and what minute peace
negotiations but your equality the
saying recently that you would not
bother them until the right time
I'm not reformed the the council right
time means the opportunity to
restructure the peace council internship
proper stakeholder representation rights
watch this is a signal of women's
partition participation is somehow
optional it's not a regard it's not
optional it's not optional the Human
Rights Commission does not speak for me
I speak for myself I hope that you're
convinced of that that you would not
attribute words of others to me when I
am in front of you and can speak clearly
and categorically that women's
participation in the beat so they will
take part in direct negotiations with
the Taliban at some point when those yes
discussions that are happening are they
going to happen again these discussions
with the Taliban we're working on how
well are you working on it how
effectively it's not for you it's for me
to determine and make the judgment do
you trust Pakistan I don't trust anyone
and matters of national interest
national interest is not about trust
national interest is about ensuring
national interest in regional
coordination you were going to trust
them with some intelligence material
weren't you we're going to share some
intelligence between
the ISI we share Pakistani we share what
is in our interest and they share what's
in their interest what is critical is to
change the definition of interest to
being able to say that terrorism is a
common threat and we need
join forces we live in a part of the
world where rules of the game
international law is incredibly weak
rules of the game between states have
not been defined but it is a mark of
trust or for the intelligence material
to offer the intelligence of a Pakistan
where we one other major thing that
their wins with honorable we have done
one episode of being able to share what
is in future necessary is to create
environment of trust between two states
the sovereignty of f1 instead must be
accepted categorically by Pakistan so
that we can move forward small issues
must not stand in the way of the big
picture 40 years of conflict must end
what happens need first and foremost is
peace in security and stability but that
within our Constitution not at any price
what is the danger that as these talks
go forward with the Taliban you will be
required to row back on freedoms we
haven't evolved will not those are not
those are not negotiable
I can catechin categorical in every
instance chapter 1 of our country which
is freedom for in Chapter 1 of our
Constitution if you permit me I would
finish my sentence it may answer your
question but should you likely
corruption then I would be delighted to
permit them to enter continuously into
my sentences please may Irish please
chapter 1 of our Constitution that's
about the character of the state as a
republic as soon as I can't read that
adheres to respect for Islam and human
rights declaration in Chapter 2 that is
about fundamental rights of the citizens
or not for negotiation as long as I'm
leader of the country this is not
subject for discussion and negotiation
so the rights of women end all have won
citizens will remain protected and
Sharia will not be prioritized over
human rights the discussion of place of
Islam should not be some reduced to
slogans
sherry is a very complex system for
instance one of the most elaborate
systems of protection of property rights
and private contracts what aspects do
you have in mind that is best left to
the proper interpretation of the
Constitution through the Supreme Court
end the constant the Commission for the
interpretation of the Constitution
President Ashraf can thanks very much
for being on complex our pleasure to be
with you thank you